[Music]
on this Monday night egregious and
embarrassing error I apologize profusely
the fury after the House of Commons
honored a man who fought for the Nazis
how could this happen
demanding Justice for a murdered
Canadian sick leader
the action protesters are pushing Ottawa
to take
the finale of the Hollywood writer
strike the mood as soon as the tentative
deal was announced was one of ecstasy
why production won't resume right away
and no longer stacking up why Legos plan
to get greener has fallen to pieces
[Music]
good evening and thank you for joining
us there are calls for the Speaker of
the House of Commons to resign after
honoring a man who fought for a Nazi
unit during the second world war Anthony
Rhoda says he takes full responsibility
and has apologized but the incident
which took place during Ukrainian
President Vladimir zielinski's visit to
Canada on Friday has become an
international embarrassment
my sincere apologies to the house to
each and every one of you who are in the
house today and to all Canadians for
having been put through this this is
something that is deeply embarrassing to
the parliament of Canada and by
extension to all Canadians we are clear
and unequivocal we believe that the
speaker needs to step down
Jewish advocacy groups have expressed
outrage over the invitation and MPS from
all parties have condemned Rhoda's
decision saying they trusted his
judgment when they stood up and
applauded
so how did this happen and why did no
one seemingly flag this person's past
before he was publicly honored David
Aiken has our top story tonight
I wish to make a brief statement a
somber sad speaker it was my decision
and I apologize profusely I cannot I
cannot tell you how regretful it is
Speaker Anthony Rhoda had invited one of
his Ukrainian constituents from North
Bay Ontario yaroslav hunka to watch
Ukrainian president veloda mirzolenski's
speech on Friday and then Rhoda singled
him out as a second world war hero and
all present stood to applaud
many would discover to their horror
later that they had applauded a man who
wore the uniform of a Nazi Soldier
during the second world war as a
descendant of Holocaust Survivors whose
majority of her family walked in to
auschwitzburg now
and only my grandfather and his brother
walked out
I feel particularly hurt hunka was 16 in
1941 and like many young Ukrainian men
of the time he joined German Army units
who were attacking Stalin's Russia many
of those ukrainians were motivated first
by the holodomor Stalin's deliberate
starvation of millions of ukrainians in
the 1930s but many also believed joining
the Germans would help Ukraine
independence here in Canada there are
monuments in Oakville Ontario and in
Edmonton recognizing the military unit
in which hunka served but hunka's unit
the 14 SS Galicia division was also
involved in war crimes in the mass
murder of poles of ukrainians and of
Jews the NDP says rota's role in
inviting hunka last week disqualifies
him from being speaker sadly I don't
believe you can continue in this role
regrettably I must respectfully ask that
you step aside the conservatives
reserved judgment on Rhoda's Fitness
instead they Folk Focus their criticism
on the Trudeau government there was a
Nazi in the chamber there's only one
entity
one group that could have done anything
about it today is Yom Kippur the Jewish
Community my community is horrified
only one office in the country is
responsible for vetting visitors to this
place the prime minister's office
the incident is now attracting
International attention Russia is using
it as recruitment propaganda and at
least one Ally Poland is demanding an
official apology nitu for all of this
David there's still that basic question
how did this happen how is it that no
Authority knew about hunka's past before
he was singled out for Applause speaker
Rhoda today said that he himself blew it
that neither he nor his staff did the
appropriate background check now the
conservatives say as you heard that's
hard to believe because they had to
provide a list of all the guests that
they invited to zielinski's speech
presumably so that they could be vetting
but here's the thing Canada's security
agencies would have checked those names
for real security threats somebody might
want to harm the Ukrainian president our
police though they do not have the
responsibility to identify people like
hunka simply because they might be a
political liability to a sitting
government that's something different
all right David Aiken in Ottawa thanks
David
security was high at several Indian
consulates and the Embassy in Ottawa
today sick Canadians held protests one
week after prime minister Justin Trudeau
made an explosive allegation linking
Indian agents to the assassination of
Canadian haddeep Singh Niger since then
both countries have kicked out diplomats
and as tariya Israeli reports protesters
want Canada to put more pressure on
India
protesters burned the Indian flag in
Toronto and spit on an effigy of India's
prime minister Narendra Modi accusing
him of having blood on his hands in the
murder of Hardeep Singh Niger India who
has masterminded the killing of Canadian
citizen on the Canadian soil Canada
kicked out a diplomat and India did the
same the retaliatory expulsions come
after prime minister Justin Trudeau
revealed Indian agents may be linked to
The Killing we would like for the
Canadian government to expel all the
Indian diplomats this was one of several
demonstrations organized by the U.S
based group six for justice the
organization advocates for a separate
six State carved out of Northern India
known as kalistan protesters also
gathered outside the Indian Consulate in
Vancouver and in front of the high
Commission in Ottawa government of
Canada and all the Western countries
have lots of power lots of clothes to
force India to come to the table the
protesters
operate with can
but for now that appears unlikely India
has called the allegations absurd and
accused Canada of Sheltering terrorists
in New Delhi protesters marched against
Trudeau and accused six separatists of
singling out Hindus in Canada in Canada
go to India this video of a member of
six for justice is circulating on social
media South Asia experts say that kind
of rhetoric may play into modi's hands
the Indian government has tried to
refocus attention away from the
allegation against it and more toward
this um this view of the Indian
government that Canada has had these
anti-india forces on its soil for a very
long time Global Affairs has changed its
travel advisory to India urging
Canadians to exercise caution because of
anti-canada protests and sentiments
a mirror of the advisory put out by
India's government last week and another
sign of how tense the situation has
become tariya isri Global News Ottawa
RCMP and BC are investigating reports of
racist signs being posted in at least
two cities signs were put up in
Coquitlam and poor Coquitlam advertising
a whites only moms and tots group it
says Escape forced diversity and join
other proud parents of European children
in a statement the city of Port
Coquitlam condemns the sign saying this
vile garbage isn't welcome in our
community or anywhere else
in Quebec today the RCMP demolished its
last building on rocksham road the quiet
Dead End Street south of Montreal became
an unofficial border crossing for Asylum
seekers in 2017. with the renegotiation
of the safe Third Country agreement
earlier this year the number of migrants
crossing at roxam has dropped but as
Mike Armstrong explains the issue hasn't
disappeared as much as it shifted
with the Demolition of this building the
RCMP says it hopes to return roxham road
to Residence we understand that our
police operation has disrupted your
quality of life the force is apologizing
to locals for the disruption of the last
six years a period that saw a hundred
and thirteen thousand migrants move
through well times have changed the
number of migrants that crosses through
Roxanne has dwindled and our presence
here is no longer necessary
the RCMP now says its resources are
better allocated on patrols along the
border
rather than at what had basically been a
funnel
roxam was an unofficial border crossing
under the safe Third Country agreement
with the U.S migrants couldn't ask for
Asylum at regular border crossings
they'd be turned back but there was a
loophole if they crossed between border
crossings and reached Canada they'd be
stopped by police but allowed to seek
asylum on March during a visit by
President Biden the U.S and Canada
announced they were closing that
loophole and foot traffic at rocksham
since has dried up migrants are still
coming just not through here this just
pushes the problem the same way he's
pushing that building down they're just
pushing that problem to other places
according to immigration officials there
were more Asylum seekers in the first
eight months of this year than in the
same period last year it jumped more
than 50 percent but at the beginning of
2023 Asylum Seekers arriving by land
outnumbered those arriving by air by
about five to one since the loophole
closed that's flipped the bulk now
arrived by air by close to four to one
now there is a growing problem police
are watching at airports like here in
Montreal migrants arriving in Canada as
tourists with no intention of taking in
any of the sites
what we're seeing is that people are
arriving at International Airport
spending a few hours in Canada and then
automatically Crossing illegally into
the United States so we are monitoring
that situation very closely
what it's all meant the RCMP admits is a
more complicated situation millions of
dollars were spent on rocks and Road
keeping it staffed 24 7. but they're now
having to watch the entire border more
closely where people crossing
increasingly in both directions
Mike Armstrong Global News Montreal
a sexual misconduct charge against
Lieutenant General Steve Whalen has been
dropped the military says the charge was
related to what it describes as an
inappropriate relationship with a
subordinate Weyland was removed from his
position as the head of military
personnel in 2021 after the allegations
were made he was set to face a
court-martial this morning on two
charges he has pleaded not guilty to a
second charge related to an allegation
he inappropriately changed a performance
evaluation report for an employee
Russian air strikes killed at least four
people in Ukraine and caused significant
damage to infrastructure at the Black
Sea port of Odessa the attacks destroyed
grain storage facilities and caused
significant damage to the seaport keeps
says the airstrikes are intended to
prevent it from exporting grain to the
world the strikes have intensified as
Kiev presses on with a counter-offensive
in the south and east that has made slow
gains it's hope the arrival of U.S made
Abrams Tanks today in Ukraine will help
boost the efforts
and Ukraine claims the commander of
Russia's Black Sea fleet was killed in
last week's attack targeting occupied
Crimea on Friday Ukrainian forces fired
a barrage of missiles that hit the heart
of the kremlin's Black Sea Fleet
destroying a section of the Russian
Navy's headquarters in sevastopol
according to Ukraine's military Russian
Commander Victor sokolov was killed
along with 33 officers Crimea has been
the key Hub fueling Russia's full-scale
invasion of Ukraine and has been a
target for Ukrainian forces seeking to
reclaim lost territory in recent months
an Italian mafia boss who was caught in
January after spending 30 years on the
Run has died 61-year-old Mateo Messina
De Niro was suffering from colon cancer
at the time of his arrest officials say
he was transferred from a maximum
security jail to a hospital prison Ward
when his condition worsened last month
dinero was convicted of numerous crimes
including the murders of anti-mafia
prosecutors deadly bombings in Rome
Florence and Milan and the kidnapping
and killing of a 12-year-old boy
a popular comedian now under police
investigation coming up the growing
accusations against Russell Brand
Hollywood is one step closer to being
back in action after nearly five months
of strikes a tentative deal has been
reached between the writer's Guild of
America and the alliance of Studios but
as Brittany Rosen reports many
Productions will remain on pause
the final scene has concluded in a
month-long economically ruinous work
stoppage by Hollywood writers the wga
and the big Studio bosses coming to a
tentative three-year deal that the union
says was exceptional with meaningful
gains and protections for writers in
every sector of the membership the mood
as soon as the tentative deal was
announced was one of ecstasy celebrities
reacting on social media LeVar Burton
happy news and Mindy Kaling see you soon
good news for consumers because it means
that late night television can resume
and production of some of our favorite
shows and movies can get back underway
though it could take several weeks
before the contract is ratified viewers
can expect late night and daytime shows
like Jimmy Fallon and Drew Barrymore to
be back on the airwaves early next month
don't expect to see things moving back
into production that quickly the vast
majority of scripted movies and
streaming shows however still likely
won't make the cut production will
remain on pause as actors continue to
strike
many of their demands higher wages and
worker protections overlap with the
writers but issues like compensation
around the use of artificial
intelligence are distinct and will
likely make it more difficult to reach a
deal what does it mean for actors to be
recorded ones and then used in
perpetuity either their bodies their
voices or both now at this point it's
unclear when actors will be able to step
back into the spotlight segafter
congratulated writers and said that it
is ready to return to the bargaining
table with these big Studio bosses but
at this rate industry insiders say it
could take all the way up until February
before things stabilize in the film
industry nitu Brittany Rosen in
Washington thanks Brittany
London's Metropolitan Police is
investigating a number of sexual assault
allegations against comedian and actor
Russell Brand the 48 year old is accused
of rape assault and emotional abuse in
London and elsewhere between 2006 and
2013. the allegations were made by four
women during a documentary and
years-long Joint investigation by
Channel 4 the Sunday Times and times
newspapers Brandt denies the allegations
stock upside down ahead how some people
became stranded on a ride at Canada's
Wonderland
Canada's Wonderland is the largest
amusement park in our country attracting
nearly 4 million guests every year but
what was supposed to be a fun night was
anything but over the weekend when a
bunch of Thrill Seekers got a scare
nobody saw coming mitral lay reports
Saturday night at Canada's Wonderland
had almost wrapped up when a crowd
started to form near The Lumberjack ride
something was clearly wrong because not
only were the Riders stuck they were
hanging upside down
Gia Shira Rivera was about to get in
line when she heard the screams from the
right people kept shouting ghettos down
they kept screen get us down
call 9-1-1 oh my God we need to call
9-1-1 oh my God the same thing happened
on The Lumberjack ride in 2021 except
that situation was resolved in under
five minutes
this most recent stoppage left Riders
inverted for a stomach churning 25
minutes in a statement Wonderland said
the Park's maintenance team responded
quickly and two guests reported chest
pain and were a 10-2 at the parks Health
Center before being released without
need for further medical attention the
Canada Safety Council says Wonderland
tests its rides daily and has multiple
fail-safes built into each one if a ride
is in operation and something goes wrong
or not even necessarily goes wrong
something is detected to be out of the
normal realm of operation of that
machine the machine will stop as they
fail safe it's unfortunate in this case
that it stopped with the folks upside
down you know that that of course is
traumatizing but from a safety
perspective the ride did what it was
supposed to they added 25 minutes of
Hang Time notwithstanding microlight
Global News Toronto
next wide Lego is taking apart its plans
to make its famous bricks from recycled
bottles
[Music]
snap is good the hold is good Maya
Turner has just made history
and with that kick University of
Manitoba bison's kicker Maya Turner is
now the first woman to play and score in
a regular season Youth Sports football
game she also converted all three of her
extra point attempts and had a
game-winning field goal in overtime
Turner called it an unreal experience
did you ever dream big of what to build
with your Lego the options are endless
but after years of searching for
sustainability the world's largest toy
maker has abandoned plans to make its
famous bricks from recycled plastic as
Redmond Shannon reports Lego is still
probably one of the more sustainable
uses we have for plastic
Lego a rare constant to cross
Generations by one estimate there are 50
bricks for every human on earth that's
about 400 billion pieces of plastic in
2021 the Danish toy giant said it wanted
to build some sustainable credentials
and make Lego from recycled bottles
instead of hydrocarbons but now Lego
says that doing so isn't worth it
because the energy needed to turn
bottles into bricks means there would
actually be no reduction in carbon
emissions the reality of plastics is
that it's difficult to find
both sustainable and practical
Replacements environmental scholar Myra
heard says oil extraction plastic
production and waste are all factors to
weigh for companies like Lego this is a
lesson in let's hold off on big praise
until
um you know those big announcements are
followed by actual change LEGO Group
says it is still testing and developing
bricks from a range of alternative
sustainable materials including other
recycled Plastics Lego fans say the
popular toy does have one built-in
sustainable trait you never throw out
Legos
and Bricks yes her name really is Anne
bricks he's from Denmark the home of
Lego at Lego from when my son was
mine on the other hand has kept her kids
Lego since they were kids so let's say
between 27 and 30 years she and her
husband Barry will only let go of their
Lego in their will I think the great
thing about Lego is the passing on the
Baton
you know so it's all three of our
children are crazy and the eldest girl
who's married she's converted her
husband so it just goes on almost like
Christianity
Redmond Shannon Global News London
and that is global national for this
Monday I'm nitu karcha tonight's your
Canada is the Royal Canadian Mint
building in Winnipeg we love seeing your
Canada please email it to viewers
globalnational.com thanks so much for
watching and have a great night
thank you
[Music]